what is
happening there spider-man fans we're
gonna watch today from chris
over at three see films spider-man no
way
home update what is happening i
don't know what he's not nobody knows i
don't
know i don't know what he's even
referring to like what a weird thing to
say i'm sure a source knows
there's a source so the title almost was
like update i don't know
nobody knows all of this is wild
speculation
let's see what's going on
he's mine if you want to get to him you
got to go through me
you'll have to go through me too yo good
luck
ain't
hey spiderman fans thanks for watching
on this video
spectacular amazing day in the
neighborhood when we get some spider-man
no way home news but
what is going on right now in the fandom
is just too wild and too ridiculous
i had to address it i really wasn't even
planning to make a whole video about
this
nonsense but movie news has been really
slow lately not a lot is going on and
then i was hit with this message right
here from good old chris baisley who
says
any new content today i've been looking
for two days
maybe i'm missing it you can thank him
for this video being made today okay i
was gonna try and spend the day sorting
out my pop collection in my new home and
trying to figure all that out but
it's overwhelming wow
christopher i've made a big mistake
so specifically what we're going to be
talking about here today with spider-man
no way home is there just been some
wild crazy things going on that i don't
remember any movie being this hyped up
with this much out of whack news also
happening because we have this supposed
teaser trailer that is obviously fake
but then we have also
movie theaters claiming that they were
sent the official poster for spider-man
away home putting them off to show to
the public and everyone thinking that
they finally saw the spider-man no way
home posters that along with some other
crazy stuff so
if you're tied up to spiderman no way
home talk let me know down below
what has been the most annoying thing to
you about the spider-man no way home
news is it everyone
assuming that people are 100 for sure in
the movie
is it the week to week day to day
everybody changing their minds that oh
this day is the trailer no this day's
the trailer trailer's coming out because
my granny said so
easily the most annoying thing on our
end is uh waking up at six a.m every
morning with a little bit of a panic
attack
that the spider-man no way home trailer
has come out
countless days of hypothetical maybe
it's going to
dramatically a lot of stress a lot of
text messaging a lot of what does anyone
know
we'll just wake up in five just a case i
don't think it's actually coming anytime
soon
i was hoping it would come before the
end of july especially because
some of you great fans out there were
letting me know that you can find
spider-man
wonder in walmart or other retail stores
right now this lucky fan went ahead and
found a spider-man mask with the logo of
spider-man no way home bought it
purchased it did all that and i just
think it's kind of wild that we have
merch for this show
but still all these internet people be
telling us okay july 22nd that's the day
y'all that's the day you gonna see some
real
and like goblin junior you gonna cry but
then out of the blue today
everyone had a feeling that we would not
be getting the spider-man no way home
trailer on july 22nd so all these fake
scoopers online who were promising that
the trailer would come out
july 22nd started backtracking for one
because we have the trailer for doom
coming out and if sony wants to reveal
the trailer for spider-man no way home
they want to do it on a day that is
clearly just meant for them to take in
that trailer but also you have people
who have no connections whatsoever
saying that the spider-man no way home
trailer was originally meant to release
tomorrow but my sources told me it's
delayed once again
oh my god has told me that the same
thing and tons of people have tweeted it
so you know i'm being for real sony
wanted to surprise people but people
knew the trailer date you're trash brock
which honestly is just one big fat
lie it's a lie sony does not care at all
if we know when the date of
we usually know write that argument
further they actually would love to let
you know
when the trailer yes and that surprised
you at all because studios
love showing off how much views their
trailer got within 24 hours that's like
become such a big thing now where after
trailer comes out we have to see
how many views did it get in 24 hours
and did it beat a record because it
somehow determines if the movie will be
successful or how many people want to
see it so
they would actually love to let you know
when the trailer is they would they
absolutely would especially sony sodi
often will let it leak or they might
even do a
trailer teaser like what they were just
showcasing here for dune
but usually like for certain scoopers
like the actual scoopers who tend to be
on top of it they have their trailer
sources
and it's like they kind of communicated
to them so that way they can report
on it to get the word out yeah it's very
common practice nowadays
sony on the other hand they're a lot
more like yeah tune in for our trailer
tomorrow it's finally coming
okay it's gonna be a lot of hype i have
a feeling sony will actually announce
when the trailer is coming oh yeah just
imagine like everyone would pale them as
saviors like if you know what they have
to do to make everyone happy is just
tell them when the trailer
better be the best trailer ever and
beside that a lot of scoopers knew that
they for venom let there be carnage
when that trailer was going to come out
i mean even made a whole video when we
found out when the date for that trailer
was
and they still released it so that
doesn't make sense to me and it's just
the most annoying part to me about this
fandom is just people
lying constantly about when the trailer
dates coming out when it's happening i
made a prediction that it would come out
before black widow because that would
make the most sense
but when it didn't i didn't make a whole
video saying my daddy kevin fegoli told
me it's canceled because i was a bad boy
today
sorry guys that's not even one of the
most ridiculous parts this part right
here is just like what is even happening
anymore is we had
actual movie theaters displaying posters
for spider-man no way home a lot of fans
thinking oh my god we got an official
look of the posters
but they're all fan-made posters like
this italian movie theater
which i think looks way more believable
as a poster for spider-man no way home
even though i highly doubt they're gonna
go ahead and reveal tony maguire and
andrew garfield in the poster when they
officially release stuff
this is a fan made poster that had been
floating around the internet for the
longest yeah
i can't believe it not to say this when
speaking to the manager of the movie
theater so like two days ago me and my
friend went to re-watch black widow in
theaters
and this poster was up on the wall you
know there was like flash through
different ones
and this was one of them and we were
like does this get released this is the
official poster
so we asked the manager because he used
to work there and he was like i mean
that's the one we got sent
[Music]
they're digital it's a poster which i
think is even all that more confusing i
don't blame this guy he probably did get
told that by the manager or the manager
just didn't even know that maybe some
employees just put it up there to have
fun and they were just joking around but
it just continues to stir up this crazy
hype for spider-man no way home that all
these weird things just keep happening
i cannot believe that happened that is
that is insane one of two things it's
either somebody some cunning
you know popcorn stan guy hacked in was
just like i'm gonna upload because
they're digital post
if they had been sent paper posters i
would have been a little bit more
on board for it but yeah someone could
have just slipped that in there for fun
or
they're having fun with us and they're
sending these out knowing that we've
seen them or something like
giving like marvel or it's marvelous i
don't know
i don't think marvel or sony's that's
not my
first guess but it's it's an alternative
i think maybe
a lot of people are asking theaters if
they have the trailer because what's
been a big discussion around the
theaters
is like i talked to my friend at amc
they said they have the trailer i talked
about
that but this theater they don't have
the trailer so this this builds hype
i think that makes people want to like
check into the theater and make them
think they have the truth
or something like that like we're going
to be sharing this trailer here in the
theater
i feel like just put it yeah just a
stupid mistake at
all could bring people in or the theater
owners because these aren't like major
chains like amc
still they're pretty there's a pretty
big theater still especially the
the one there in michigan that looked
like a reasonably big theater
they had a rack of oscillating digital
poster screens they can't be hurting
that much
exactly that's my point is that maybe
they got fooled or something like that
maybe it was employees but i i can't
believe it's gotten to this point
where maybe the theater managers or the
owner thought that this was a real
poster like that is
nuts to me yeah it's just the multiverse
bleeding over all the posters from the
various timelines
we recently got reports that they're
doing reshoots on the movie which
shouldn't alarm anybody
all movies nowadays plan for reshoots
just to tweak up a few things
even some people went ahead and noticed
that charlie cox went ahead and
cancelled an appearance because he had
some unexpected reshoots to go back to
there's spider-man race it's also
happening the only thing he's working on
ever
yeah it must be that one seed that he's
in
stop the whole thing and re-shoot just
this one moment
we got him for one or two seeds and we
need to reshoot those one or two seeds
that could just be a major coincidence
but that gets me excited of the thought
that daredevil has to do some reshoots
for spider-man no way home but it does
go without saying that it's kind of
weird that sony is breaking their rule
right now of the six-month mark of
releasing a trailer for spider-man and
now we're getting to the point where
we're almost
less than five months away we're about
to be four months away and people are
like yo
what what is what's going on here why
it's the most hyped movie of the year
doesn't matter
saving money now lately that i could see
sony maybe planning to do it and make it
a big major event since they know the
hype is real
where for movies like maybe ghostbusters
or venom let there be carnage which i
think would be the most likely scenario
is they do something like with what
jurassic world
they would not do that movie is doing
work they want to break the internet
to see this film you'll get five minutes
or ten minutes of spider-man no way home
for you to check
i would be pissed off for them to do
that yes it only takes one person to
record it on their channel
put it on youtube and then no one will
go out to see yeah i would be
pissed if they do that are doing a great
job of just talking about this movie
non-stop and promoting it to everybody
and their mother that sony's like why
waste our marketing dollars when the
fans are doing it
exactly exactly month mark hits they're
like all right here's a little trailer
that barely shows anything
you know you're buying a ticket welcome
to the spider-verse but that is just
something i wanted to get off my chest
and bring to you guys i really want to
know from you what do you think of all
this madness happening with spider-man
no way home have you ever felt
this much hype for a movie do you
believe all these wild and crazy things
are happening i mean just take a look at
the playlist of all the spider-man news
i've made of how many weird leaks or
giant coincidence have happened with
this movie that it's like
who's doing all this don't forget to
like subscribe follow mentor at 3c film
review
as always i'm chris take care see you
buddy great video chris fantastic video
loving the setup
loving all the pop all your pops off man
look that is some crazy info that is
some crazy
wild with the po thanks for reporting on
that buddy guys subscribe to 3c films if
you haven't done so already
fantastic videos it's been killing it
lately hit the like button on our video
subscribe for more we will i
in the middle of finalizing a sketch
that
we're planning on putting at the
beginning of whatever the hell that
spider-man
trailer comes out catch you guys soon
thank you so much for being here